في قرارات التي نتخذها
لسنوات
المقبله سوف يكون لها تداعيات للعقود
الثلاثه او الاربعه القادمه كما قال
الرئيس في ظل رئاسه
بايدن سوف نعمل على رسم ملامح الاوضاع
الاستراتيجيه التي سوف ترسم شكل العالم في
المستقبل ان هذه المقاربه كانت هي جزء لا
يتجزا من سياسه الخارجيه نركز في خلالها
على نقاط قوتنا في الخارج ويتم ذلك من
خلال
الاستثمارات التي تصب في جوهر قوتنا وفي
مخزون ما نمتلكه من نقاط قوه في بلادنا من
خلال اتباع هذه الاستراتيجيه الحديثه
للاستثمار في نقاط قوتنا وما تتمتع به
البلاد من نقاط ايجابيه استطعنا تحقيق
اهدافنا ولاسيما ان اهدافنا كانت محطه
ايجابي وقبول الحزبين وكان هناك كما
تعلمون
قانون مسوده قانون البنى التحتيه التي
لقيت قبولا من قبل للحزبين وكذلك قمنا
بتمرير قانون حول
اشباه الموصلات التي ادت الى تعزيز هذه
الصناعه في المستقبل وكذلك الامر يطال
الذكاء الاصطناعي والتكنولوجيا وما شابه
ذلك المنافسه في التكنولوجيا سوف تكون هي
الاشد سوف نكون في وضع يسمح لنا الفوز بها
في القرن الرابع والعشرين كما فزنا بها في
القرن العشرين كذلك مررنا قانون تخفيضي
التضخم والعمل على زياده الاستثمار قدر
الامكان بما في ذلك في مجال الطاقه
النظيفه وهذا سوف يضع الولايات المتحده في
دفه القياده لاداره الانتقال في مجال
الطاقه بحيث لا يكون هذا الا محطه اهتمام
بكافه شركائنا حتى في الشرق في ظل هذه
الاستثمارات في الداخل فكرنا ايضا في مدى
الوضع الاستراتيجيه الذي يمكن ان ياتي من
نتائج في القوه الاستراتيجيه للاجيال
المستقبليه ومن ثم الوقوف على تلك القوه
وتطبيقها في اماكن مختلفه في العالم بما
في ذلك في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
دعوني اقول بوضوحا وبصراحه ما ذكر الرئيس
بايدن بنفسه ان التزامنا نحو منطقه الشرق
الاوسط لا يهز لان هذه المنطقه تعد مهمه
للغايه لمستقبلنا وكذلك
تتشابك مع مصالح الولايات المتحده
وشركائنا الاخرين اذا ما نظرنا الى الصوره
الكبرى منذ قد منذ جاءت هذه الاداره الى
شده السلطه وكنت اعمل معها ومنذ خبره في
في مجلس الامن القومي وعمل به كاثر من
لمده تفوق 14 عاما فان من
فهو قد اكد جنرال مارك ميلي رئيس هيئه
الاركان بانه باننا ننظر الى منطقه مليئه
بالضغوط ومليئه بعمليات التصعيد القوات
الامريكيه
وطواقيم الدبلوماسيه يتعرضون لعمليه
هجوميه مستمره وكان هناك عمليه هجوميه
بالصواريخ في العراق هي الاكبر من نوعها
وكذلك الاداره الماضيه قامت بتهديد
بالتهديد باغلاق السفاره في بغداد مما كان
يشكل نكسه كبيره للمصالح الامريكيه ليست
في العراق بل في المنطقه برمته وقبل
تنصبه العرش كان الرئيس باد او عزبي بشن
ضربه ضد بعض المشاهد وبعد ذلك قمنا بشن
هجمه ردا ودبلوماسيه بالعمل مع العراقيين
في المنطقه لتعزيز المواقعنا والحد من
المخاطر
وحتى هذا اليوم فان الهجمات في العراق قد
تباطات بصوره انترم بصوره حديثه مع
الاداره العراقيه في الحكومه الجديده
وكذلك ايضا مع المنطقه هذا ليس الا بمثال
وليس بوصفا لاجمالي لكنه
يلقي بالضوء حول المخاطر التي نجدها والتي
تستلزم رسم سياسه تعتمد على الرضع
والدبلوماسيه من اجل تحسين الوضع الاساسي
للولايات المتحده وحمايه طواقم
بالاضافه الى ذلك كان لدينا وجهه واضحه بن
من اجل حمايه مصالحنا
والتصدي للتهديدات الارهابيه والعمل على
التصدي للصراعات الماضيه والحديده وانا
هنا لا اشير الى مساله انتصار قد تم في
العراق لان الهجمات قد تتجدد وقد وقد تبدا
في اي لحظه وسوف نقوم بالتصدي له لكن هذا
ما رايناه على الاقل خلال السنتين
الماضيتين وخلال تلك الفتره راينا ايضا
نتائج كبيره قد تجلى سوف اتطرق اليها
الاتفاق البحري
الجوهري بين اسرائيل ولبنان واول توافق قد
تم بين لبنان واسرائيل في تاريخه هذه
الاداره وايضا الهدنه التي استمرت ل 14
شهرا في اليمن منذ انطلاق الحرب هناك قبل
عقده من الزمن والحرب بين لبنان وغزه لمده
11 يوما ومحاولات مستميته للتوصل الى سلم
مستدم والتقارب بين تركيا الامارات
العربيه المتحده واسرائيل والبحرين
والامارات وقطر والتنافس بين تلك الدول
المتنافسه في الشرق الاوسط لسنوات طويله
قد كله قد تم ترميمها من خلال المصالح
المشتركه حتى ايضا الدبلوماسيه بين
السعوديه وايران التي بقينا من خلالها على
اتصال لاسيق مع السعوديه من بغداد للتوصل
الى هذا الاتفاق هذا كله يتماشى مع
التوجيهات الاساسيه لتخفيض التصعيد الذي
لطالما دعمناه وشجعناه رغما من رغم
استمرار وضعنا ضغوط على ايران وكذلك ايضا
التخلص من كبار الارهابيين بما في ذلك
امير داعش وبعض
الشخصيات الارهابيه المعروفه التي تهدد
بلادنا وحلفاء في ظل وجود تركتها المستمره
وفي نفس الوقت سعينا لنكون مبتكرا وابداعي
ومبدعين فقط وصلنا الى اتفاقيه ابرهم
لا استطيع ان ابت بان هذا قد بانها قد
حملت نتائج مثاليه لكنهم لكنكم لعلكم
تتذكرون من خلال خطابي باننا بان هذه
الشراكه كانت قويه وهناك شركات ابرمتها
الولايات المتحده ايضا مع الهند والامارات
العربيه المتحده والهدف الاساسي هو ان يتم
تعزيز مصالح الولايات المتحده في جنوب شرق
اسيا من خلالها يتم الاستفاده من
التكنولوجيا والدبلوماسيه وقد قمنا سلفا
بتنفيذ مجموعه من المشاريع من خلال اتخاذ
الخطوات مثيره للاهتمام نتطلع لتحقيق
نتائجها في الاشهر القادمه الميجا فور وهي
التي تعد التجمع الاكبر للمسؤولين العرب
للبحث التعاون حول قضايا تتعلق بالامن
والتغير المناخي والتجاره والتعليم
وكذلك قمنا بابرام صفقه كبيره لتشكيل قوه
متعدده الجنسيات في
من خلالها وضع ترتيبات امنيه في عقاب
اتفاقيه كامله لانها ليست اتفاقيه حفظا
للسلم حسب المضي قدما في طريقي التكامل
الكبير وتصدير العلاقات بين الاطراف الذين
كانوا على خلافات منذ عقود من الزمن وعلى
كذلك قمنا ايضا بفتح الاجواء في عمان
لتحقيق الرحلات الجويه
الاسرائيليه بين عمان فوق عمان والسعوديه
كل هذه الامور لم تحدث من قبيل المصادفه
وبدفعه واحده بل كان ثمره ثم قمنا به من
رسم اطار للسياسه الذي قام الرئيس بايدن
بالاعلان عنها خلال زيارته للمنطقه العمل
الماضي وتم دمجها في الاستراتيجيه التي
كنت قد تحدثت عنها في مطلعك كلمتي وهي تقع
في جمله من الصفحات التي كانت قد استمدت
من استراتيجيه 2021 منذ البدايه حتى هذه
اللحظه كنا نسعى الاتباع هذه المنهجيه في
المنطقه
الاستراتيجيه الاساسيه هي واقعيه ويمكن
تطبيقها وتطال مجموعه من الدروس التي
تعلمها وكذلك الوعود في عمل في اجراء
عمليات التغيير وهي متفائله وطموحه يمكن
لحلفائنا والولايات المتحده تحقيقها في
فتره وبهذا يرمي لتحقيق
التقدم المستمر من خلال اتخاذ خطوات
مستمره وو بنات الاساسيه للتواصل لاستقرار
شامل وازدهار
للمنطقه والشعب الامريكي وهذا سوف يكون
المسار الافضل للسياسه الامريكيه هذا
الاطار الجديد للاخيرات الامريكي في
الولايات المتحده قد بني على 5 عناصر
اساسيه الشراكه والردع
الدبلوماسيه وتخفيض التصعيد والتكامل
والقيم
واود ان اعرج على كل من هذه القيم وكل هذه
العناصر وما يدور في خلدنا سوف ابدا اولا
بالشراكه على مر السنتين الماضيتين عملت
الولايات المتحده مع شركائها في المنطقه
بدءا من المغرب الى مصر الاردن العراق
الدول مجلس التعاون واسرائيل
ومع ان قمنا باداره حوار استراتيجيه من
خلال زيارات الرفيعه المستوى بما في ذلك
زياره الرئاسيتين وتم اجراء بعض التمارين
العسكريه كلها مستمره بالتشاور المستمر
والانخراط لضماني
شركاتنا سوف تعتمد على كافه عمليه التواصل
فيما بيننا كذلك ايضا قمنا باقامه شركات
اساسيه من خلال منتدى المنتدى
الاكبر او الميجا فورم الامر الذي يعود
بالنفع على شعوب المنطقه ويخص المواضيع
المياه والصحه وتغير المناخيه والامن
الاقليمي في حقيقه الامر في نهايه الاسبوع
هذا سوف اتوجه الى السعوديه الى الاجتماعي
مع القياده هناك وكذلك نظرائي من الهند
والامارات سوف يتجهون الى السعوديه لعقد
اللقاءات بحيث يمكننا ان نتطرق الى مجالات
مختلفه من النقاشات بين الميودل ودول
الخليج والولايات المتحده وبقيه دول
العالم من خلال الشراكه الشامل التي تم
توقيعها بين الهند والامارات في العام
الماضي وهذا سوف يسمح لنا للمضي في قضايا
الجوهريه نرى بانها لن تشبه اي شيء كنا قد
رايناه في المنطقه في السنوات الماضيه على
نحو المشابه في السنه الرئيس بايدن
ومجموعه من قاده الدول الخليج قاموا
بنشر مبادره الاستثمارات التي ترمي لتعزيز
الاوضاع في دول المنخفضه الدخل في الشرق
الاوسط وتعزيز
وتعزيز سلاسل الامداد نعلم ان هناك جمله
من المشاريع التي تصل قيمتها مليارات
الدولار تعتمد على خطط الحديد
واستخراج المعادن بدءا من افريقيا والشرق
الاوسط عندما تنظرون الى هذه المسائل والى
هذه الشركات ولا جمله من التحديات التي
تطرقت اليها فانني قد وصلت الى نقطه في
هذا الخطاب بان التركيز على تلك العناصر
من بالنسبه لي كمستشاره امن القومي قد
تكون حصه مختلفه ولها مكان مختلفه في
مساله تعزيز مصالح الولايات المتحده في
المنطقه من خلال العمل مع الشركاء في تلك
المنطقه في التصدي لتلك لكن في العالم
الذي شرحته في مطلع حديثي في هذا العالم
المحفوف بالتنافس والتحديات العابره
للحدود لابد لنا ان ننظر بصوره متزايده
للمنطقه بانها مصدرا قد مليء بالشراكات
سوف تساعدنا على حل المشاكل التي تعترضنا
الدول ان تساعدنا في تعزيز سلاسل الامداد
بحيث لا نعتمد على دواء دول بعينها ودول
تستطيع ايضا ان تعمل على انجاح
الانتقال للطاقه السلميه للطاقه النظيفه
امرا ممكنه ممكنه سوف يتم نشر سريعا
للطاقه النظيفه وايجاد الحلول للمشاكل
الغذاء والمياه التي باتت الجوهريه ليس
فقط لحل مشاكل العالم بل ايضا لحجم الطلبه
المتزايد الذي نسمعه ايضا من قبل الدول
الاخرى في ظل المنافسه اذا هذه المبادره
للسلم في الشرق الاوسط قد تكون جزءا
للسؤال المطروح وهو انه لماذا الشرق
الاوسط لا يزال مهما انه ليس مهما فقط على
بناء على طبيعه الامور التي اعتدنا على
رؤيتها في العام 2003 بل فيما نراه الان
عام 2023 وهذا سوف يرمي لتعزيز الجهود
التي قد تساعد الولايات المتحده على تامين
دينار
وسوف نعمل على التصدي لكافه التهديدات
وتامين الشراكات بطريقه
اكثر فعاليه كنت قد تحدثت عن التحديات في
العراق والتحديات في المنطقه عندما كان
لدينا وجودا عسكريا من خلال تحالف كان
يرمي
لاثماء لارساء السلام وفي سوريا وفي شهر
مارس ايضا كنا قد راينا هجوما الذي قد
اودى الى مقتل احد
المتعاقدين الامريكيين هناك بالاضافه الى
بعض
الموظفين الامريكيين الاخرين الذين تعرضوا
لاصابات كان هناك رد مباشر وخلال ساعات
قمنا بضرب المناطق في سوريا التي يتم
استخدامها بعض العناصر التابعين للحرس
الثوري الايراني والان نرى على الاقل لهذه
اللحظه تخفيض في عمليه التصعيد ضدها
طواقيمنا في سريه لكننا مستعدون للرد
في مواجهه اي خصم قد يستهدف طواقمنا في
العراق او في اي مكان اخر في هذا الغضون
وكما اسلفت الحديث سوف نلقي ضغوطا مستمره
على داعش كما حدث في الضربات التي حدثت في
مطلع الاسبوع الماضي وقالت احدى زعمائها
والتخلص مما يسمى بالخلافه كذلك عملنا مع
شركائنا ايضا للوقوف على بعض التهديدات
التي كانت من خلالها ايران تشن عملا
هجوميا
في مواجهه السعوديه ان التعاون بين
الولايات المتحده والسعوديه افضل الى
افشال ذلك الهجوم وفي مطلع هذا العام
قامت الولايات المتحده واسرائيل باجراء
اكبر تمارين عسكريه يمكن تخيله في تاريخ
هذين البلدين مما نشك فيه
اننا نقوم بتنفيذ اقوالنا ولا نقوم
بالادلاء بها فقط هذه التمارين العسكريه
قد تبعها ايضا مجموعه من التمرينات الاكبر
في المنطقه حيث اكثر من 50 شريكا دوليا
بما في ذلك شركائنا في البحريه
الخليجيه والاسرائيليه الذين انضموا الينا
كذلك ايضا ننخرط مع ايران من منظوره
دبلوماسي وما زلنا نؤمن بانه كان خطا
ماساويا ان يتم التخلي عن الاتفاق دون ان
يكون هناك اي بديل لكننا نقول لايران بانه
لن يسمح لن يسمح لها بالحصول على سلاح
نووي كما كرر ذلك الرئيس بايدن بانه سوف
يتخذ الاجراءات الضروريه التي يمكن من
خلالها تاييد اقوال بما في ذلك ايضا
اعطائي الحق لاسرائيل في اتخاذ
الاجراءات المطلوبه وهذا ياخذني الى
العنصر الثالث الدبلوماسيه والردع
وتعزيزي العلاقه الدبلوماسيه مع شركائنا
هو مكون اساسي لكن الدبلوماسيه وتخفيض
التصعيد ايضا
يحظى بنفس الاهميه في استراتيجياتنا وفي
كل يوم نجد
النتائج المثمره لزياده جهودنا
الدبلوماسيه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وهذا
ما تحدثت عنه في مطلع حديثي بما في ذلك
ايضا
التخلص من الجراح التي قد شابت العلاقات
بين دول الخليجيه في السابق وفتح الحدود
البحريه للمره الاولى بين لبنان واسرائيل
ووقفي الحرب التي دارت بين غزه واسرائيل
هو اول اجتماع مباشر بين مسؤولين
اسرائيليين
الصينيه منذ عشر سنوات وقد قمنا باعاده
حاله الوحده بين الولايات المتحده واوروبا
ضد
الاستفزازات الايرانيه
وما تقوم به من جرائم ضد شعبها ونشر
السلاح
الى اوكرانيا واليمن وعملنا ايضا على
تخفيض الصراع في ليبيا من خلال اتخاذ
ترتيبات لتشاطر السلطه هناك
ولعل المنطقه الاكثر اهميه التي ركزنا
فيها في مجال الدبلوماسيه والرداء هي
باننا عملنا على تخفيض التصعيد بصوره
واضحه في اليمن واود ان اعرج للحظه للحديث
عن اليمن لانها تظهر مدى اهميه
الجهود الدبلوماسيه والرده وهدم ما
تعلمناه من السنوات الماضيه في عام 2020
وقبل تولي سده السلطه كانت اليمن منطقه
ساخنه وكانت الدبلوماسيه
متوقفه وحاله كبيره من الصراع سمتها العنق
ليس فقط في اليمن بل ايضا طالت السعوديه
وما ابعد من ذلك وبعد ان جاء الرئيس الى
سده السلطه وبعد ان تولى الاداره كان قد
القى خطابه الاول في وزاره الخارجيه وعين
مبعوثا خاصا باليمن واتخذ قرارات صعبه
بتصنيف الحوثين لمنعهم من من شن اي حروب
وبسبب ما اقدم عليه
بالاوضاع الانسانيه للحالات الى حاله
مزريه ومنذ اليوم الاول قد عملنا بصوره
دبلوماسيه لوضعي
لتشجيع المحادثات المباشره وفرض والتهديد
بالضغوط على الحوثين ومن يدعمهم من ايران
وعملنا ايضا على مساعدتي السعوديه
والامارات للدفاع انفسنا في وجه التهديدات
من اليمن واماكن اخرى وكذلك ايضا قمنا
بتعزيز اعمالنا بصوره مباشره في تلك
المنطقه من خلال
والان سوف اتطرق الى المسار الذي اعتمدنا
عليه والانجازات التي حققناها وهناك مبعوث
تم تكليفه للمنطقه
وسوف تكون مهامه موضوع نقاشا في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه خلال هذا الاسبوع
للوقوف على الانجازات التي حققناها حتى
اللحظه
هذا يظهر ما حملته الدبلوماسيه من ثمار
بعد ان تبنت الولايات المتحده ذلك التعاون
اللسيق مع شركائها
بمعنى ان الدبلوماسيه والردع كان يصب في
مصلحه المنطقه والولايات المتحده على حد
سواء اما العنصر الرابع من سياستنا فهو
التكامل
ونحن نعمل بصوره متكامله مع شركائنا في
الشرق الاوسط لتامين السلامه والازدهار هو
تخفيض
المطالب التي قد تحتاجها الولايات المتحده
من المنطقه دون اي دون احداث اي تضحيه في
هذا المجال نعمل على تعزيز قدراتنا
العسكريه وهي مساله لطالما تحدثنا عنها
منذ فتره طويله لكن بفضل هذه الشركات
التكنولوجيه يمكن تعزيزها لعلكم البعض
منكم قد زار الاصول الخامس البحرين
واطلعتم اعينكم على
القوه موجوده هناك التي تستخدم الذكاء
الاصطناعي
من اجل تامين الممرات البحريه في المنطقه
وطالما حضينا
بالتاييد
على هذه الشراكه المتطوره التي يمكن من
خلالها حمايه مصالحنا المشتركه للسنوات
المقبل اننا نقوم بتعزيز قدرات من اجل وصل
خطوط الكهرباء الى العراق والاردن ونساعد
وانه نشجع كافه الاستثمارات الدوليه في
هذا المجال وكذلك ايضا ندعم موسى صفقات
للسكك الحديديه بين البحرين والهند
واسرائيل ونعمل على بناء انظمه
بيئيه للتكنولوجيا الجديده من خلال شركات
اساسيه سوف يتم ابرامها بين السعوديه
والامارات وسوف نعمل على تعزيز نطاق
اتفاقيه ابرهم ودعم اسرائيل من اجل
التكامل
مع المنطقه والاندماج فيه ومع العالم
وهذه مساله سوف تكون محطه اهتمام من خلال
الفتره المقبله في سياق نظرتنا لاضافه
مجموعه من الدول التي قد تنخرط في علاقات
تطبيع مع اسرائيل وابعد من ذلك المهم في
كل هذا الامر ان المفتاح الاساسي
او ان الهدف الاساسي يكمن في التوصل الى
منطقه متكامله بالتعاون مع الشركائنا في
هناك اخيرا القيم
التي
يجسدها ميثاق الامم المتحده
العالمي لحقوق الانسان لا يمكن ان ان لا
يمكن ان تنفصل عن مصالحنا كلكم قد اثرتم
جمله من المخاوف بشانه حقوق التعبير وحريه
النشر
وهذا ما قد شدد عليه الرئيس بايدن خلال
زيارته وكذلك انا
وكافه اعضائي في الفريق نعمل على هذه
المساله لان الرئيس بعد ان قال بان
المستقبل سوف يكون للشعوب التي يجب ان
تحضى بكافه قدراتها الكامل اي بمعنى
العمل على تعزيز حقوق الانسان اي بمعنى من
حق المواطنين ان ينتقدوا قادتهم دون ان
يخشوا
اي عمليات انتقام او ثار وانت ان يكون
القاده مسؤولين عن تصرفاتهم تجاه شعوبهم
وفي مراحل مختلفه في تاريخنا كنا ساذجين
في عدم ادراكنا
لقدراتنا ما يمكن تحقيقه من خلال القوى او
من خلال الدبلوماسيه بل لكن باتت الصوره
واضحه لدينا اليوم بان ان قيمنا في تلك
المنطقه لن تبدل ولن تقوض
اعطنا الجهه الفاعله التي لا تعمل بطريقه
تلتصق مع قيمنا ولا تتفق مع رؤيتنا
لمجتمعا عادل ومنصف
وفقا لميثاق الامم المتحده والاعلان
العالمي لحقوق فسوف فنتحدث عنهم
علانيه
الى ان يتم تحقيق النتائج المرجوه وسوف
نفعل ذلك ايضا بطريقه
يتم من خلالها خدمه مصالح حسنات طويله
الامد التي تعد في ذات الوقت المرتبطه
بقيمنا وهذا يضمن باننا سوف ندفع باتجاه
باتجاه تعزيزي كافه مصالح شركائنا الذين
يؤمنون بمثاق الامم في ذلك تلك الدول التي
تدين غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا والعمل على سبل
انسانيه بحيث يتم توفير المناطق للشعوب
التي تعيش حياه افضل كنا اكبر دوله مانحه
على المستوى الثنائي في في اليمن وسوريا
في حقيقه الامن الامر في اليمن لم نقم
بالعمل بذلك بل ايضا عملنا على تخفيف في
المعاناه التي
طالت التحديات بيئيه تتعلق بالناقل
النفطيه الصافر دعوني اختتم كلامي
باستراتيجيتنا حول الشراكه
الشراكه هي المبدا الاساسي في مقاربه
الرئيس بايدن
هذه نقاط القوه التي بنينا عليها سوف تمهد
الطريق لبناء نقاط قوه جديده وهي سوف
تنطبق على المنطق المنطق
من خلال كافه التهديدات مثل التغير
المناخيه والانتشار النووي
والانظمه
الانظمه التكنولوجيه التي يمكن من خلالها
العمل على ضمان عيش الشعوب بحاله كريمه
ان المستقبل الولايات المتحده سوف يكون
مرسوما
بقدر التحول في الطاقه والتغير في
التكنولوجيا والتغيرات الديموغرافيه فضلا
عن المسائل الاستراتيجيه التي لطالما
تصدرت المشهد في المنطقه وباتت اكثر
ديناميكيه واكثر قدره على المساهمه في
ارساء الحلول طويله الامد التي نعيشها في
لحظات هذه مفترق في مفترق الطرق في
التاريخ الولايات المتحده سوف تبقى شريكا
اساسيا
ينبع من خيار هذه المنطقه وهي ميزه اساسيه
من خلال الطريقه التي نقرر
بموجبها العمل على تعزيز تلك الشركات وسوف
نعمل على
تعزيز السلمي والامن في المنطقه من خلال
عملنا مع مجموعه من الدول في مواجهه تلك
التحديات هذا ما نسعى للقيام به ليس لدينا
فقط تحديات تتمثل ببرنامج ايران نووي فحسب
وما تصبه من نار على الحرب في اليمن
والاعمال الارهابيه المستمره وانتهاكاتها
المستمره لحقوق الانسان لكن هناك جمله
من التحديات التي لابد من التعامل باعها
في المنطقه بصوره مباشره
والدبلوماسيه في ظل تلك الازمات كنا قد
جربناها من خلال عملنا وتحدث عنها الرئيس
وهذا ما فعلناه في اليمن وفي سرعه اخرى
لكن الصوره التي اسعى لرسمها بالنسبه لما
نعيشه اليوم والمستقبل الذي نسعى لبناءه
مع مجموعه من الدول وبعض الجهات الفاعله
الاخرى في المنطقه هي تلك الصوره التي تت
رفع بنا
الى التوصل لامكانيه
يمكننا من خلالها ان نتصدى لهذه التحديات
للجيوسيه بدعم من شركائنا فنحن بحاجه الى
شرق اوسط متكامل من الشرق الى الغرب بحيث
يكون جزءا لا يتجزا من العالم الاكبر
هذه الادوات التي نسعى لنشرها للتوصل الى
النتائج وقد حققنا تقدما في هذا المجال
لكن الرحله لا تزال طويله وفي الفتره
المقبله
والخطوات المقبله سوف نعمل
من خلال اجتماعتنا في السعوديه يوم السبت
ايضا المزيد من الامور هذا كل ما لديه
اقوله اليوم لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات